modern science generates a lot of data
amounts far beyond the ability of humans
to process on their own this is why
scientists often rely on computational
methods such as machine learning a type
of artificial intelligence to crunch big
data in fact is pretty commonplace today
and is even used in applications like
Spotify and Netflix to help protect your
media preferences but there's a problem
traditional approaches to machine
learning such as deep learning are
focused on classification and
statistical correlation this makes them
very useful for recognizing and
comparing patterns in things like audio
or images but not very good at
discovering what might have generated
the patterns in the first place
understanding these so called generating
mechanisms in other words the dynamics
of cause and effect is a fundamental
challenge across all scientific fields
from decoding how a complex biological
cell arises from DNA to figuring out how
a thunderstorm forms from differences in
air temperature and humidity such tasks
require abilities such as inference or
reasoning which most artificial
intelligences are not designed for to
tackle these challenges one team of
scientists are developing a
revolutionary new form of machine
learning which they've called causal
deconvolution by algorithmic generative
models which basically means breaking
down complicated and interconnected
datasets to look at the underlying
mechanisms or code that generate them it
aims to find the individual underlying
algorithms that give rise to a dataset
in a sense treating natural phenomena as
computer programs generating observed
data so we can think about this with a
visual analogy if we have a table with
several objects on it and we lay a cloth
over it represented with a unique 3d
terrain and this represents a mass of
collected data some of it relates to the
objects underneath and some dozen modern
machine learning which is based on
classical statistics is good at
identifying objects by comparing
features such as shape to previous
examples it's been shown
when it can't do it has much about how
the objects underneath were formed the
aim of this new methodology is to first
work out which bits of the terrain
relate to the different objects this is
the deconvolution part and then to
identify the objects by looking at how
they might be generated this is done by
testing lots of possible coffee cup hats
or book generating algorithms and
looking at how these could influence the
tablecloth arrangement so unlike
traditional machine learning it attempts
to infer how the objects might have been
generated to match the observed data but
this isn't just intended to work on
imaginary dinosaurs it's hoped that it
can be applied to help scientists
unravel the dynamics of cause and effect
in fields such as genetics and cell
biology for example in understanding the
complicated gene interactions that give
rise to cancer and that's because this
methodology moves away from
classification and towards questions of
causation providing insights and models
to help us understand the underlying
mechanisms behind observed data so as
machine intelligence continues to
develop researchers may become
increasingly reliant on a eyes which
shrink less like machines and more like
scientists
[Music]
you